Das kommt Mama Bertone exklusive neue
App Ich klicke auf Zoom Der neue 3m9-Film für Kinder Neuer Kindertisch
Oh das ist viel auf dem
Econo-Ausdruck Wir sperren die
Invasion Sara in die andere Richtung Wenn
jemand einen Farmbus füllt die Niederlande die
neuen Kinder MIDI Renoir und  charakter an so
bis nom mag sponsern okay also
nochmal dein mikrofon und hier sind die
fragen in unserer frage madhuri die
grüne sind harmlose fragen die
roten sind fiese fragen yeah yeah
also kannst du dich entscheiden okay du kannst es
einschalten yeah yeah an  ein ende und dann
das andere und dann funktioniert es aktuell neu
total ich folgt einem neuen morph
ich denke das ist unser humor wir mögen groben
und unhöflichen humor wenn es reißt ja wir machen es nicht
absichtlich aber es ist wie unser
mensch ja wir  nur gegangen Ich bin nur gegangen, wenn
es am Rande oder am Rande ist Ich mag
Humor der nächsten Stufe und nicht den einfachen
Alltagshumor, also ist es keine Absicht,
aber ich, es ist mein Geschmack, okay ja,
oder er hat Sie davon überzeugt, dass ich nicht ich bin
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir einen Evo-Tiefs machen  Humor Ich glaube,
wir machen alle unterschiedliche Arten von Humor,
also nein, das ist nicht das einzige, was wir
schreiben. Ich denke, okay, nächste Frage,
rot oder grün, rot,
Tildy,
ja, ich finde eine wunderbare für mich.
Endlich, wir sind bei einem anderen Sketch
, das ist Ted  Wenn wir Witze über sie machen,
ja, es ist ja, als ob es um deine
Region geht, sind es die Absteiger, du benimmst dich so,
nein, weil es überlebensgroß ist, was wir
tun, also denke ich, dass sie es alle wirklich mögen
, weil es aus dieser Region stammt, ja
, also, sie sind es  wirklich
erkennbar für sie, ja, es gibt
fiktive Charaktere, also ja, das ist,
glaube ich, deshalb mögen sie es, sonst
hätten wir einen Dokumentarfilm machen sollen,
es wäre auch wirklich cool, aber nicht so nicht
so lustig, ich denke, es ist so lustig, Mama, okay,
ein bisschen langweilig, ich  denke okay nächste
frage du wählst nur die roten
ja da sind sie nicht also sind sie nicht so verrückt
wie ich wo es selten vorkommt das du die erde bewegst
version
wirst du ein süchtiger was ist ein erwachsen
wann oh wann bist du ein erwachsen ich nicht
Weißt du, Mann, ich bin 31, also bin ich, ich glaube, ich bin ein
Erwachsener. Ich mag das nicht. Ich weiß nicht, ich bin
über 18, also bin ich erwachsen
Ich weiß, ich bin es nicht, es
fühlt sich an wie ein H-Ding. Ich denke, es ist immer
gut, jung zu sein. Also, ähm,
ich weiß nicht, ich hoffe nicht, dass ihr Leben
dann einfacher ist. Ja, ich meine, heutzutage
können die Leute wählen, was sie wollen  tun,
was sie mögen und winken - man
muss heutzutage nur für Geld arbeiten
es wird langweilig, wenn man den ganzen Tag
langweilt und sie
halten sich daran Ich mag es nicht,
erwachsen zu sein, meine ich  Ich wünschte, ich könnte ein Kind bleiben,
okay, nächste Frage, ein grünes, okay, eins
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir uns nur eine lustige Situation ausdenken, es kommt ein Witz, also denke ich
, es ist wirklich so, dass wir es zusammen
machen, Witze erfinden, und dann gibt es eine Art
Verbindung, und dann funktioniert es
Du denkst, du brauchst euch beide, um auf diese Weise lustig zu sein
, ja, ich denke, wir bleiben
sehr scharf, weil wir beide
einen wirklich guten Witz mögen müssen, also wenn jemand
damit nicht zufrieden ist oder so, Mann,
es ist nicht so lustig, dann ist es nicht  lustig,
also sage ich, ich verliere viel und dann behalten wir
nur die besten, sie springen heraus, okay, also
eine rote oder beide - sie sind beide rot
, oh, okay, okay, wie die grünen
, mehr, jetzt ist dhanoa hema
, sie werden nicht gezeigt  Wir sind Comedians mit einer neuen
Generation von Comedians. Ich denke, wir haben
den Humor zu der Komödie gemacht, die sie
machten, von der wir dachten, dass sie nicht existiert. Wir
vermissten unsere Art von Humor im
Material und im Fernsehen
neue Generation
ja was sagt so noch zwei
Fragen und dann ist es fertig es ist dieses
Tannenblatt tut es ich für den Kern
garniert erst Ellen muss wenn Stella
meint ist es nicht peinlich das
du handeln musst finde ich gut
das wir jetzt meinen  Wir handeln wirklich, wenn
Sie uns anschauen möchten  Im Moment sind wir ein
bisschen anders als der Kerncharakter.
Ich denke, dass du jetzt
schauspielerst. Ja,
wir spielen gerade
von Schauspielern
von der Schauspielschule in Holland,
die wirklich Theaterschauspieler produzieren und so.
Ich glaube, sie könnten nie Charaktere
wie Carrie und Tickets spielen, also denke ich, dass
es ein wirklich großer Vorteil ist, dass die
Jungs eine Art Verbindung zu
diesen Charakteren haben  plus die
charaktere die fünf charaktere wir
schreiben sie zu ihren eigenen persönlichkeiten also
hey der kleine er ist im wirklichen
leben auch wirklich wie schau mich an schau
mich an ich bin lustig ich bin lustig
also passt es zu ihm und mir '  Ich bin kein großer
Redner, also rede ich nicht viel in dem
Film, er ist immer hungrig, also
schreiben wir sie an die Charaktere, damit
es weniger schwer zu spielen ist, aber sie sind immer noch
Schauspieler. Ich denke, es ist schwierig zu spielen
solche Rollen für einen Schauspieler, weil die  Sie sind
nicht realistisch, sie sind so besonders, dass es
für Schauspieler sehr schwierig
ist, zu spielen, ich denke, weil wir mit
solchen Charakteren im wirklichen Leben aufgewachsen sind, als man diese
Charaktere sehen und diese Charaktere
kennen musste, die man so spielen kann  Es ist
wirklich schlimm, wo du herkommst, ich denke,
ja, du musst es verstehen, und wenn
du nichts darüber weißt, wenn du
aus einer wirklich reichen Familie stammst, hat er die
Schauspielschule in einer Großstadt besucht, dann
weiß ich es nicht  Ich glaube nicht, dass Sie dies tun können. Sie
können eine Rolle wie diese verlassen, damit das wirklich
funktioniert. Ich denke, das ist ja, deshalb
funktioniert es,
weil wir verstehen, okay,
letzte Frage, Website, Website, oh, wenn ich nur, wenn
Sie Blut brauchen  weiß ich bin
kein bär ich bin nicht schnell verlegen nein ich
weiß nicht nein ich bin nicht nein ja ich weiß nicht
wofür wir uns schämen sollten
so über alles was du tust dein telefon
über alles was du tust  Xing yeah yeah
also spielst du eine rolle und und du machst es
gut ich denke und du machst es gut oder du
yeah ich th  Tinte, es ist wichtig, einfach
dein Charakter zu sein,
während du drehst, also ist es jetzt nicht
peinlich, weil du. Ich denke, wir sind
eher stolz als verlegen. Ja, ja,
okay, also vielen Dank
und es ist sehr schön hier in rauch nein
ich hab spaß schlau ich konnte nicht was
trinken
tschuldigung ja das werde ich tun vielen dank